[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
having a bit of technical difficulty
today
oh boy
oh boy oh boy well that's just how it
goes sometimes that's just how it goes
sometimes headphones aren't working
microphone aren't working can you folks
hear me out there testing testing one
two one two can you hear me in the chat
oh boy
sorry I took just a minute
um
that sounds good they said everything
sounds good hey okay well we're gonna
see how long my airpods battery last
here now hopefully I'll be able to um
make this work I don't know we'll see
today if
we can make it work I'm not sure how
we're gonna get there uh oh by the way
the FBI is hanging out on the beach
today I don't know if you guys uh heard
about the FBI hanging out on the beach
so
um
it's gonna be bad for Trump trust me on
this just trust me don't doubt me I'm
telling you it's gonna be absolutely
horrible for Donald Trump and the
trumpers
um that is just how it's gonna work
you're not going to convince me
otherwise you're not going to convince
me that somehow this is horrible for
Biden horrible for Biden's re-election
campaign in 2024
I'm muffled yeah I'm I'm on a different
microphone and I promise I'm gonna try
to switch
um here soon
um so it's just my regular mic is for
whatever reason something's not working
this morning
so I even restarted my computer before
we started
uh let me let me see if I can get the
Gabe Sanchez
see if I can get him on board here
[Music]
dude I'm still not getting anything out
of my uh regular mic
it's very frustrating very frustrating
you can hear me and it just sounds a
little different probably because it's a
different microphone it's just a little
different microphone but we have a guest
today
um Hi-Fi from the uh radicalized podcast
is going to join us
um sometime in the first hour here I
believe about a quarter till the second
hour he's going to be joining us to talk
about a subject that he wanted to come
on to talk about uh so me and Gabe
welcomed him on the podcast today so he
will be joining us as well and someone
said that need a headset no I got I got
my airpods in and that's um what you're
hearing the uh
I believe that's what you're hearing my
sound and uh yeah that so you're getting
you're getting the microphone for my
airpods
and I can hear in my earpods so
what a [__] show this morning with the
technical difficulties it happens every
once in a while especially when it's
just you running the whole show you
don't have you know a whole team of
folks
it's just you it's just me just me here
running the show starting the show and
then we have Gabe Sanchez that does the
art and he helps produce uh once we get
going here
so that's just how it goes so you know
what I should do because I was going to
give my opinion on exactly this beach
house search which that is
um that is important I want to give that
opinion on the beach house search but
first up I want to I don't know maybe I
should just do promotion since you know
and technical difficulties anyways
people
um you know
getting confused by the microphone sound
not having the headset on it looks a
little different today what do you guys
think do you think I should go without
the headset
I always have my headset on see I always
get my headset on
what should I go without the headset
from now on is this a thing that we
should do I like my headset because I
don't have to rely on battery
I just plug it in and I can always hear
it's the nice part about the headset I
mean I can always have it as backup
some people are saying nice haircut yes
without
Everyone likes without well maybe
maybe we'll just do it without the
headset and for those of you are
listening uh because we download
our upload excuse me we upload you
download it uh every single weekday this
podcast on Apple Spotify and Google so
they can't see me over there
right they can't see my beautiful
haircut
on the audio version so if you're
listening on the audio version you
definitely should come subscribe to the
YouTube channel and check it out every
once in a while
the the video version of the Tony
Michaels podcast
all two hours
all two hours every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central on YouTube Twitter and twitch
speaking of that you should go download
the Twitch app I told you I'm going to
do some promotion here so just hang with
me I'm going to give you the opinion
about the beach house thing the beach
house search here in a minute so go
download the Twitch app it doesn't cost
you a thing everyone over on Twitch
we've got several subscribers already I
I don't even exactly know how it works
but apparently if you log in
with your Prime account and I think the
moderators might know this if you go to
Twitch and log in with your prime Amazon
Prime account you get one free
subscription
and you can use that subscription for
the Twitch app
and then uh it's ad free over there but
also we make a little bit of changes
that a lot couple bucks but it helps out
it helps out with all the technical
difficulty
well they're a pain in the ass they're a
pain in the ass and if you're watching
on Facebook right now if you're on Midas
Touch Facebook page make sure to go
follow me at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook why not why not you'll get to
go see my videos and all the memes that
I post on Facebook and then spread them
around
like herpes you can spread those means
around like herpes all
over Facebook and all over the Internet
really I find them sometimes I make them
very rarely but most the time I find
them
and I'm like okay this is a good one so
I'll go post it on Instagram and I'll
post it on Facebook so go follow me on
Facebook at Tony Michaels but just go to
the tonymichaels.com the Tony
michaels.com type it in doesn't take
that much or the links down below the
tonymichaels.com all all the links are
there like all the social media
that I what I post on Instagram Facebook
wherever you want to follow me at it's
all there masted on
um post is it post news I can't keep
track of all these social media
platforms they sent me an email the
other day wanting me to open the account
I guess now I was on the list to wait
for this social media account you heard
of this post-op news some [__]
oh boy frankly I am I am exhausted with
how many social media uh accounts that
you have to have I'm almost considering
closing them all and just doing maybe
one or two it's kind of frustrating it
really is
because I post the same [__] everywhere
and it takes forever to post the same
thing on all of them and each one's a
little different so you gotta it's a
pain in the [__] ass it really is
it really is to have it six seven
different ones do you guys really follow
me on that many of them anyways do you
want to follow me on that many of them
I don't know maybe I'm crazy maybe we
should pare it down and not you know
broadcast this on Twitter maybe we
should just stick to YouTube and and and
and twitch maybe not even do Facebook
anymore I don't know a lot of you watch
on Facebook though
if the people on Facebook if you if you
had to go somewhere else would you watch
the show would you listen to it I don't
know it just it frustrates the hell out
of me that's why I kind of like this
patreon thing a lot of people have been
joining the patreon thank you very much
for all your support over there
I think today I'm gonna do the first
shout out video so everyone look out if
you're if you're in the patreon
and yet and yet you you selected a tier
where you get a shout out pay attention
today pay attention
um because I'm gonna do my my idea and
you can tell me if you like it or not
you can criticize the [__] out of me if
you don't like it if you're like ah that
sucked I want something different fine
whatever I I mean I'm I'm open-minded
here but today I think I'm gonna do my
first shout out for the patrons that
that got into the top tier with the
shout outs here so
go go over to patreon take a look at
that now join if you want to it's only
it's only five bucks to join patreon and
support the show and support my content
and I appreciate that a lot so maybe
we'll have a conversation over there
about this social media thing and so
many goddamn social medias it's [__]
ridiculous
it's it's ridiculous
that you got to have 15 different
[__] social media accounts right am I
wrong about that I mean I know a lot of
people like no I'm not getting on this
social media platform not doing that one
not doing that one and I I'm like I I
totally understand that I totally get it
but you don't want to have 15 [__]
different social media accounts that you
have to try to go post on or keep up
with or the comments
um it gets it gets exhausting it gets
difficult and then you got all the all
the [__] all the [__] messages and
and stuff that people send you all the
comments it's just it's hard
it's hard
it is [__] difficult
um some people are saying stick with
Mastodon
um listen
I mastodon's not bad and I post the show
over there but it just it I mean
I don't know
it's it's cool that they're not gonna
let any Nazis on there or whatever you
know but I don't know it's it's
difficult to navigate it's weird and
maybe I'm doing it wrong
um same way Facebook Facebook's so
clunky to me I don't know how you people
navigate on Facebook
I just don't get it I don't get it
and maybe it's not for me to get
but there is one thing for me to get
there is one thing for me to get
is for to tell you
exactly why this beach house search
today that's going on I don't know if
it's still going on or if they wrapped
it up I don't know how big his beach
house is I haven't seen pictures of it
yet I really don't give a [__]
um this whole beach house thing now this
beach house is in Delaware I I can't
remember the exact place that it's at uh
let me see let me see if I can uh
the place that it was at was trending uh
earlier yeah oh God damn this Tom Brady
[__] we'll talk about that today too
we'll talk about Tom Brady and how that
doesn't make a shith hill beans were the
difference and why America is falling
behind because they pay attention to
[__] like that
oh where is it what the hell's the the
name of the beach house anyways who
gives a [__] the point is this is that
the FBI was welcome the Department of
Justice was welcome by Biden and his
attorneys to come search the beach house
in Delaware Biden's beach house
in Delaware
why is this significant the reason why
it's significant is because the House
Republicans wanted an FBI search
remember remember that that's what they
wanted Jim Jordan wanted the FBI on
Sunday with Chet Todd why hasn't the FBI
searched Biden's residence
they're doing it and Biden welcomed them
right
the problem is
is that it's his Beach vacation home
and Obama Benton
you're going to find an absolute [__]
thing
at this beach house
and that's the point like that's the
whole [__] point they're not
gonna find [__] at the beach house not a
goddamn thing is what they're gonna find
and it's really gonna make the
Republicans look like they [__] the bed
totally [__] the bed on on the whole
I'll Biden Hunter Biden laptop let's say
the Pledge of Allegiance because that's
a distraction I'm gonna talk about that
to you today they're trying to say the
Pledge of Allegiance
oh and Pete Aguilar just absolutely
destroys him we'll go through that clip
today
but listen the reason why this beach
house search is horrible for Trump and
trumpers and the House Republicans is
because every single time something
happens that they want to conflate it
ends up [__] the bed the whole time
the entire time they don't have 100
binds laptop don't have it never will
have it it doesn't exist it's not a
thing that is
a thing it's only made up in their
[__] minds
this whole documents being the same as
Trump it's only made up in their minds
and the reason why that this hasn't
really worked its way into the national
narrative yet is because the media won't
focus on two words intent and
obstruction intent and obstruction do
you know why I know that this beach
house search that they're doing today
that the FBI is doing at Joe Biden's
Delaware Beach House
you know why because when you when you
look at those two words intent and
obstruction those two words do not exist
in this beach out search not even close
there's no way if there was Criminal
Intent to steal documents
and the documents that the criminal tent
was intended for
at this beach house would Joe Biden his
team of attorneys welcomed the FBI and
the Department of Justice to come to a
thorough search of that residence no
[__] way not nope not gonna happen no
[__] no human being that has a brain
would let the Department of Justice come
search a house where there's where there
is evidence of Criminal Intent and
obstruction
that's why Donald Trump was so [__]
pissed off
when a judge issued a [__] search
warrant based on three statutes
broken with intent and obstruct and
obstruction to his home or his apartment
his Corner apartment his sleazy Corner
apartment at the [__] rundown golf
course that is Mar-A-Lago that's why
different
cannot you cannot say
in any story this morning
not one journalist I mean the the
[__] rights gonna lie about this
they're gonna lie about this
totally [__] lie
but the reason the reason why they're
gonna lie is because there's no intent
and no obstruction no intent no
obstruction remember those two words
intent and obstruction
and when you're talking about the Biden
or even the Pence documents or whoever
the [__] they find documents for for
former government officials
no intent no obstruction it is different
with Trump there was intent there was
obstruction that's why they issued the
[__] warrant
to go search his residence against his
will
Insanity to me
it's Insanity to me some people are
saying my audio is is failing
it's a possibility I'm going to switch
my mic when we go to the Break
um so that way I have a different mic on
so um and and it could be a lot of
different things I was having technical
difficulties
um
when we started the show I was having a
lot of technical difficulties so it was
um it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna have
some effect but we're we are going
and spading in and out there's things so
let me do this let me go to a break when
we come back I'll see if I can get the
mic situation fixed don't go anywhere
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum [__] them we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
okay I might have got my uh mic fixed
thanks to what I'm gonna have to do how
is that how's my sound now does my sound
sound better or worse
or can you hear me
I don't know sounds better they said
yeah it's a little better microphone
and I just had to dig it out and
get her hooked up here sounds better
they said
yes and much better much better it's a
different microphone it looks like I'm
still talking into this one but nothing
nothing's happening with this one so I'm
actually got a spare mic here
just in case just in case
this were to happen Okay so let's get
back to the beach house [__] all
right and because this is why it's going
to blow up in Republicans face the House
Republicans in particular because they
really want to have a house committee on
uh making sure to absolutely
make it look like the documents cases
are the same but they're not because
they'll never talk about Trump's
document case right
they're never going to talk about the
the actual facts in that case
but it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because we're going to
find out the facts in that case there's
a special counsel investigating that
documents case and we definitely are
going to find out by the end of this
year by the beginning next year if
there's not charges by March
against Donald Trump because here is the
here's the here is
the thing
is because of the Criminal Intent
of those documents because Donald Trump
stole our documents to cover up his
attempt to overthrow our constitution
that and then he obstructed
the Department of Justice and Nara to
get those documents back
even after he stole them
it's the whole point
that is the entire [__] point
the intent and the obstruction with with
the Mike Pence case with the Joe with
the Joe Biden case
there's no intent no obstruction
no intent no obstruction and I'm sure we
may or may not
hear from
the special counsel Arts get a special
counsel in the Mike Pence case
I I would imagine
if you look at the timeline of the Joe
Biden because everyone gets this wrong
these stupid [__] in the media
get this wrong noise
why did why did Joe Biden get a special
counsel assigned to him two seconds
after they found that that is not true
that is not true
not even [__] close
to being true
here's what happened they found
documents they got Nara and the doj
involved in the in the uh the Penn Biden
Center documents that they found that
had classified markings on them they
realized
that these documents were not supposed
to be there and they handed them over no
obstruction
that was back in November folks
all the way back in November
now they have a special counsel so I
would imagine it's going to take a
little while for a special counsel to be
assigned to the Mike Pence case if it's
not her the current special counsel in
the Biden's case because these two
things are the same I know you want the
the the the Mike Pence case to be some
sort of Criminal Intent and stuff but
um I just don't see it
you would not
let me tell you something there is no
[__] way anyone under legal counsel
where there was Criminal Intent
and they were going to find a crime in a
search would voluntarily let the
Department of Justice and their
residents are in a building to search
that building if there is Criminal
Intent afoot no [__] way no [__]
way would any good attorney say yeah
that's a great idea you there's evidence
of Criminal Intent let's let the
Department of Justice come in and look
that's why Trump was so upset when the
[__] FBI came and searched Mar-A-Lago
he was [__] pissed
because they were gonna find crime
the crime he was trying to hide the
crime he was trying to obstruct it's not
difficult to understand these things and
the media does such a shitty job at this
they do such a shitty [__] job
when they cannot and will not admit to
the fact
that the difference is the intent
and the obstruction
there is no Criminal Intent and no
criminal obstruction in the Mike Pence
and Joe Biden document case because
frankly the the Trump document case has
nothing to do
with how easy it is for people who have
access to classified documents to
inadvertently move documents that have
classified markings on them to different
places
it has nothing to do with it he stole
those documents with criminal intent to
cover up his attempt to overthrow our
government and his collusion with Russia
and I believe he stole them he stole
them to sell them and to destroy them
that's the [__] facts
so [__] facts read the [__] search
warrant read the goddamn warrant that
the federal judge issued based on the
evidence that Nara and the doj collected
to give probable cause for that judge to
believe that they needed to go get those
documents because there was crime afoot
regardless whether the it was the
original intent of the crime which is
one of them and then the obstruction
of Investigation of crime that's it
all Lisa here on Facebook I think she's
very upset at me because I'm telling the
truth lies lies lies lies lies
oh Lisa I hope you come back every day
please
follow me on Facebook would you at the
Tony Michaels and come watch every day
and get into the comments
we've missed fake Gabe for a long time
maybe you are fake Gabe I don't know
but we've missed him uh here for a long
time and we really
foreign
lies lies lies
um
and that this is this is the defense
they have right they can't they can't
put together uh deductive reasoning uh
rationale logic
um they can't put it together with any
kind of narrative that happens
um I was watching a clip of uh Jordan
kleppers uh you know Jordan klepper from
The Daily Show he goes to the Trump
rallies uh Walter our friend Walter
Masterson does the same thing
um but this clip particular clip he
asked this woman about who's the
president and this woman claims that
it's that it's uh Trump and the military
took over in the military and Trump were
actually controlling the Denver
government so Jordan klepper asked her
in that moment right there with the
microphone and the camera in front of
her face says well then who is sending
the aid to Ukraine
and she's so delusional so [__] down
the rabbit hole of Ridiculousness
she's got the Q Anon drug like a
[__]
so much so that in that moment she has
to make up something so that she's still
correct
right she has to make up something in
the moment and she's like well there's
there's two militaries there's the good
military and there's the bad one okay so
so so Nana boo-boo stick ahead and doo
doo type [__] Lisa you're the same thing
it's the same thing here I am here I am
telling you telling you what is
happening trying to explain to you why
you're a [__] bonehead and believing
chewing on lies and you're saying no
you're the you're the liar because
you're not saying what I want you to say
you're you're fake news because you just
you don't say the things that make me
feel good
kick rocks Lisa No don't kick racks
stick around stick around maybe some of
this [__] will sink in your brains as a
matter of fact go subscribe to YouTube
Lisa
go over there to the YouTube channel And
subscribe you're gonna need it two hours
every day come listen to the [__]
truth you may think they're lies now but
maybe we'll convince you also follow us
on Twitter Lisa at the Tony Michaels pod
maybe that'll help
maybe that'll help and follow me on
Facebook because you're on Facebook
right now at the Tony Michaels you'll
follow us over there also we have a
brand new network that we are that we
are posting this show Live on YouTube
the upwire.com it's a Creator Network
that is happening more and more creators
are banding together to push the
national narrative messaging with their
content so go to the upwire.com and
follow the up wiring all the social
media accounts there's going to be more
and more content over there for more and
more creators creators that I know I
know you'll love
and if you're on Twitch right now make
sure to log in with your Prime account
and use your one free subscription for
the Tony Michaels podcast to make sure
you're
your experience on Twitch is ad free you
don't want those ads do you I don't want
them I don't like ads so subscribe over
on Twitch and you should go check out
twitch it's a great way to watch it's a
great way to catch up it's a great way
to on all the issues if you want to
watch the Tony Michaels podcast if you
get frustrated with YouTube or wherever
you watch try twitch try it out try it
out if you don't like Facebook you don't
like Twitter you don't like YouTube go
check out twitch and you can subscribe
there
again you can use your Prime account
your Amazon Prime account to get one
free subscription and the app is free
too so it helps out in support of the
show everyone I know I've already taken
a break
we've had the microphone issues today it
seems like we got the microphone issues
fixed
um so I appreciate it and yeah and and
and so and and you know hanging around
through the difficulties here is always
why you're the best audience in the
world and thank you to the mods for um
helping out uh this morning as I get
through my uh
my audio difficulties it's just
technical [__] I don't know why my main
mic isn't working probably some update
that I need to download that I forgot
who knows who knows point is we're here
everyone stick around we're gonna be
right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
audio issues
what are you gonna do
get better equipment Tony I I really I
think it's a software issue it's not an
equipment
that I use every day
I don't know maybe I again maybe I
didn't download a uh the uh the upgrade
or whatever the hell the the I don't
know the update whatever the [__] it is
I don't know
I don't know maybe we'll get Gabe
Sanchez's opinion
when he gets on here he's supposed to be
coming on soon we're gonna have a guess
we're here in about 10 minutes and we're
going to talk about some Russia stuff I
believe which is something we don't
normally do
um but in the meantime while we wait for
Gabe I want to play this clip I found
this clip uh from Aaron ruparta this
morning
um where the hell uh
here it is
yeah this is um
uh let's see that's how Dem should
respond to uh Matt gatz now um Matt gatz
introduced an amendment
to
um say the Pledge of Allegiance before
the Judiciary Committee now I don't know
if you know this
but
but here's the thing
is that Jim Jordan is the chair of the
Judiciary Committee
what the f what the [__]
is the reason why Jim why is Jim Jordan
the chair of the Judiciary Committee you
asked that doesn't make sense he what is
his experience other than being a
wrestling coach that doesn't report sex
crimes
what is his experience for Judiciary
well it's not about judiciary
it's not about what is real and what is
fact and what is reality
what it's about
is theater
political theater and of course this
amendment here
is political theater
watch watch what happens as the Democrat
introduces an amendment
to the amendment this is [__]
fantastic
thank you Mr chairman I um you know Mr
Isa just made a reference to how
important it is for us to display our
commitment to the Constitution and to
commit to defend it aggressively
so I'd like to offer an amendment to the
amendment uh adding in the second
paragraph where the chair May designate
an individual to lead the pledge of
allegiance to add the following language
provided however the pledge shall not be
led by an individual who supported an
Insurrection against the government of
the United States in any way
all right Gabe Sanchez have you seen
this clip this morning I haven't but
that that sounds about right man you
can't pledge to you can't pledge
allegiance to the flag of America you
know the United States of America if you
also try to just be its [__] demise
right well what's funny is is they walk
straight into this track oh yeah right
and Republicans always run face first
into this problem and always everyone
they run face first and they it's it's
really amazing it's like they go through
a brick wall and it's like they're the
Kool-Aid man right and like oh yeah and
they just keep running through they
think they're cool they think they're
cool and Matt gatz thinks he's really
cool here so what happens is because
Matt Matt gath thinks that he has he's
got him by the by the sack here right
and really honestly I don't think that
he goes far and not Matt gets the the
Democrat oh okay I don't know you were
saying
yeah he doesn't go far enough right
um because Matt gatz is our argument is
going to be well all we did was just all
we did was just just just contest the
results in Congress in in the joint
session no you didn't yeah no you didn't
you [__] had a scheme to delay
the certification so that you could
submit fake electors that's what you did
that's what you did so yeah and now he's
on you know Ari Melbourne the beat and
other places being like look I'm not for
political violence and he also basically
admitted that he was a little [__]
because what he said was if there's
political violence you won't see me
anywhere near that I'm gonna run away
like uh I don't know another person in
the in the Senate well you know here's
the thing uh Matt gatz is a little [__]
and let me show you why watch this
because I think if we adopt this
amendment then we will be truthful in in
representing that stating this pledge is
an affirmation of your defense of
democracy and the Constitution it's hard
to take that claim seriously if in fact
individual who in any way supported an
instructed against the government United
States is allowed to leave the pledge so
I would ask Mr gates to accept this
friendly Amendment and I look forward to
supporting with a gentleman yield when I
first asked Richard Gatesville support
the amendment
to make sure that someone who led an
Insurrection against the United States
doesn't make a mockery of the Pledge of
Allegiance and stand before this
committee with their hand over their
heart claiming to support the
Constitution Mr Cellini my concern would
be if your definition of an Insurrection
is objecting to electors then there
would be many Democrats on the committee
that wouldn't be eligible to lead the
pledge in so many that's not my
definition I mean the last Republican
president gets sworn in absolutely
so he thinks he's got him right he's
like oh I got you [__] he's been he's
been making that same argument on
another stations where he's like oh well
Democrats have done it it's all just
procedural
yeah well what about that Democrats
never ever ever
have had a scheme to make sure they
stalled the certification of a
presidential election so they could
introduce fake and fraudulent electors I
mean Democrats also never never carried
through a mass of people a giant Trump
make America great flag that was
literally holstered up by a metal beam a
like a metal rectangular beam that was
on wheels that [__] ain't light right
well they never did well and they've
also never had hundreds of people
arrested and prosecuted right for the
violent Insurrection that happened on
that day and and also they've never had
a a congressperson like Matt gatz and
Marjorie Taylor green who tried to go to
the to the lock up where they were in
the federal holding lock up to free them
and because he did that he did that with
Margaret Taylor green he did that hit
this scumbag literally on it's on tape
they made sure it was yeah they made
sure it was so let's let's see and of
course
he doesn't play into his games he said
yeah absolutely if the Democrats did it
let's do that let's make sure and and he
even directs to Jim Jordan's uh
Direction here which is [__]
fantastic watch this George Herbert
Walker blaming My Time Escape I will
allow the chairman to determine whether
or not someone has participated in
instruction United States I think this
language is important with the gentleman
further yield I'm asking Mr Gates will
you now accept the amendment well I'm
I'm concerned that that you may be
disqualifying too many of your own
members Mr system I'm not concerned
about that at all then agree to the
amendment let's make this real if you
want to give someone the right to stand
before the house Judiciary Committee Now
Matt Gat's real you can see in his face
that he realizes yeah he's a guy stepped
in [__] oh [__]
oh [__] I [__] waffle that [__]
between my toes
we tried political theater and then they
did the whole I don't know doing
political theater see this is what
Democrats miss a lot of times this is
what liberals Miss in this country that
they're a [__] circus on the right it
is just a bunch of [__] clowns on the
right
but we have to have our circus on the
left we have to do political theater on
the left and and yeah does it feel gross
sometimes maybe but it's for the truth
because the truth simply is that hey I
don't mind if there's Representatives
leading the Pledge of Allegiance so they
can pretend that they're Patriots but
let's not pretend that they didn't break
their [__] oath and possibly
committed crimes with conspiracy to
commit sedition when they were trying to
not just contest the election on the
house floor which is their right with
their vote but they were trying to stall
to make sure that fake and fraudulent
electors were put into Mike Pence's hand
so Donald Trump could steal the election
which is which is sedition that is
sedition and not to mention how they
encouraged to incite a violent
Insurrection from a mob of trump
supporters but not only that they've
claimed their political prisoners after
blaming them that they were black lives
matter and antifa and God it goes on and
on and on with the lies and again it's
not surprising coming from this schmuck
but let's finish the clip before we go
to our guest and lead the Pledge of
Allegiance at a bare minimum let
guarantee that that person has not
participated or supported or in any way
anyway an overthrow of the government of
the United States with the gentleman a
simple proposition it does seem like a
simple prophecy it's a pretty it's just
a it's a yes no question right like
should people who participated or led
the Insurrection or incited an
Insurrection be able to you know
in a hypocritical fashion put their
heart or put their hand on their chest
and then pledge allegiance to this
country and the flag
when they were [__] on it for a
whole day I mean more than just a day
but that day specifically you know
should we be able to do that no it's
very simple no you shouldn't be able to
do that because then what does it stand
for it loses all meaning in all purpose
if you just say well if somebody decided
that they were having a little whiny uh
whiny fit and tantrum and they didn't
like the outcome of the election they
decided they wanted a [__] bombard
the capital with a bunch of
[__] smearing uh insurrectionists then
yeah it's like you know you don't get
that same right you don't get the same
right to to play Both Sides to to waver
in both lanes to be an insurrectionist
but then be a patriot and then be in
interactions and being patreon and so
that's really what Matt Gantz is doing
here is doing the whole both sides of
the same [__] right right oh both sides
are the same which they're not they're
not the same they're not the same one is
fundamentally against democracy and
wants autocracy the other one disagrees
a lot like it's a huge Coalition right
like there's people who are socialists
Democratic socialists there are people
who are liberals there are people who
are consider themselves moderates
Independents never trumpers former
Republicans inside the pro-democracy
Coalition that is the other side yeah of
the people who want autocracy speaking
of autocracies speaking
of autocracies and murderous dictators
our next guest might have something to
say about a specific murderous dictator
in an autocracy Hi-Fi has been on our
show before the last time he was it was
almost a year ago wasn't it uh yeah when
the whole when the whole
trucker yeah yeah so we had Hi-Fi on and
you guys should go um follow the YouTube
channel because we've got that um there
on the YouTube channel that interview I
believe somewhere and we'll have to find
it but there's yeah it's there somewhere
with Hi-Fi where the in the Canadian
border the Canadians and we got a lot of
Great Canadian people that watch us I
love our show but they add this stupid
thing where they were clogging up the
Border because
of mandates or some stupid [__] but of
course they were just trying to push
Putin's agenda of autocracy and to tear
down democracy that's the whole point
and Hi-Fi came on and he had some data
uh and I don't even maybe we should ask
him how that turned out
um but he's here for another reason
today and we've got him for about 30
minutes or so I believe so let's let's
introduce Hi-Fi Hi-Fi how are you my
friend how have you been hey all right
man what's happening ah well I had a
little audio issues this this morning
but I I fixed those sort of I I'm
running on a different mic actually you
can't see it but
I wouldn't I would not have even known
did you did you not notice yeah I always
sound great it's just a manner of it the
microphone's picking up I thought it was
the mic that's right in front of you
look at this well lean in all trickery
it's all tricker it's all trickery it's
just it's all Wizardry this mic isn't
working there's one below it uh as my
backup Mike but that's why I have it as
as a backup mic just in case this kind
of [__] happens that's okay and that
actually leads me to my next point which
is technology yeah uh good technologists
always have at least one backup and
hopefully more right I've got more but
they're not quite as handy my my yeah my
quick Handy Backup was my airpods but
they didn't quite they didn't cut the
mustard and the chat was like Hey the
sound's cutting in and out something's
happening so I had to go to a break and
break out the spare mic just in case
um and of course the box and all the
accessories are laying all the floor
because I had to rip it open I had to
get it out but but I've looked it up
before I made sure that it's worked
before as a as a backup it's a quick
steady backup just in case I think it's
a software problem I've got the uh
sounds like a user error hey [__] you
um
I've got the Elgato Wave 3
um and because I don't know if the is
aware of this but I like to scream
sometimes and my volume changes no and
it's you right not at all but this
microphone has a great um the best way
to describe it is it levels out when I
yell and scream right
um so this microphone is very good at
that that's why I use this microphone
the one down below is isn't quite as
good at it so I'm not going to be
yelling well I probably will on Scream
I'm not gonna lie
um but I just can't keep track of my
levels with the with the spare mic but
it's okay everything's good we got you
here so let's talk about why you want to
come on but first
first I want to ask we engine almost a
year ago with the Gibson go and I know I
know the Canadian government because
this happened in Canada
um so the Canadian government really uh
did a lot of follow-up on that Gibson go
and if they're who was given that money
and I know you you worked through the
data was there any result from that
um as we sit here today or are we still
working well it did turn out that the uh
you know I originally got involved in
all of this because of the Written House
fundraiser on Gibson go and I don't care
about writtenhouse I don't want to talk
about him but uh what it turned out you
know I talked to the CFO Jacob Wells
asked him to take down the Rittenhouse
fundraiser he said no
I found a whole network of billionaire
Silicon Valley oligarchs and uh a
Russian oligarch in the network behind
that fundraiser uh so I've been keeping
an eye on Gibson go then we found the
Canadian thing and it turns out the CFO
Jacob Wells uh accidentally ended up
with like 3.9 or 4.9 million dollars of
their money in his account and uh
yeah it just gets yeah but the reason I
brought a technology is is you know I've
been on this will be the second time I'm
on your show and I've never really
established my credentials so I just
wanted to like 30 seconds show your
audience some of the stuff I do so I do
a lot of infrastructure things I do uh
let's see if I can pull it up here we go
is it sharing or no uh I can share it
here there we go there we go so I write
I write technical articles articles and
I it's really geeky nerdy
stuff that nobody really cares about but
the reason I bring it up uh one of the
things I did when I was in the
technology field is I actually started a
group called EMC world beardos and that
turned into an organization called B
beards which I'm wearing my
hoodie
so V beards was an experiment by me uh
in what you could roughly call cognitive
Warfare I created a spectacle I drew
people's attention to it I got people to
join me in creating the spectacle and
the spectacle ended up an International
Group
uh that for men or women women can put
on fake beards and you know I'm
internationally known for this and and I
wanted to bring that up because it plays
into what we're going to talk about with
Russia
and cognitive Warfare
so
so let me stop you there because you're
saying the words cognitive Warfare and I
always my goal is for everyone no matter
who is listening no matter who knows
what about what political issue or what
kind of uh geopolitical enemies that we
have is to understand exactly what what
you're trying to say when you say
cognitive Warfare or what you're saying
is this misinformation
waterfall that we have on social media
is that what you're referring to where
where it seems like not only is it real
accounts that are disseminating this
misinformation and a lot of times
appears to be Russian propaganda it is
um but but also it feels like there's a
lot of bots in the background that may
or may not be real people and may or not
be in this country they're in Russia
um making it's actually not just Russia
well right then to Slovakia Slovenia
well wherever the [__] yeah Eastern
Europe yeah the point the point is is
that I'm trying the point is that I'm
trying to make is that the the what
you're saying when you say the cognitive
Warfare is that it is it is the the
waterfall of misinformation and not only
that it is the artificial way that is
used to
um pump and use algorithms to make sure
this is in front of many people and as
many eyeballs and in many ears as
possible is that is that what you're
saying exactly it's it's actually okay
so first off words matter so yes
understand our words the first word is
this information and disinformation is
information that is malevolently spread
to cause a reaction of some sort right
and this may be real or it may be real
fake or or other yeah it could be real
it could be fake it could be it could be
a different slant on events right it
could be a different camera angle
of oven again it could be selective
editing oh a riot right you know uh we
had Dr Mia M bloom on our show and you
know people were calling her telling her
they were so sorry about the riots in
Atlanta and was she okay what actually
happened was you know like two or three
Starbucks Windows got broken and some
idiots had a dumpster on fire or a cop
car on fire I'm sorry and uh they made
it seem like it was Armageddon that's
the selective editing right so that is
that is disinformation and then once you
have you you know you have people who
intentionally spread and they're
generally
um your big influencer counts people
with a you know a whole bunch of
followers uh
I'm not going to name names but anyway
it's very obviously oh why not why not
let's name names [__] them [__] them
I'll name them what which whisper them
into my ear and I'll tell the audience
okay I mean you have people like Jack
basobia okay yeah my piece of [__] Mike
cernovich uh Frederick Brennan I mean
there's all sorts of people right
there's a whole there's also very very
sensitive too if you ever call them out
and alive or on their comments they will
immediately block other snowflakes right
well here's here's the thing because the
reason why I think it's significant of
which accounts is because
um you know these these [__] scumbags
all rub elbows together because Jack
Jack prostate that you're saying that
that's his name right jack prostate
something like that yeah yeah piss boy
I'm not really sure the pizza gate guy
he is always yeah always always
a tied to Charlie Kirk at the hip and I
don't know if people know who Charlie
Kirk is but Charlie Kirk runs an
organization called turning points USA
which on our show not only is it a
scumbag [__] uh alt-right America
First Nazi type organization that
supports
um fascism but they also are trying to
bleed propaganda into universities and
other schools around the country and the
other thing that they propagate is the
the the the charter schools and private
schools and privatization of education
so they can uh um indoctrinate fascism
because when they're saying they want to
die but that these are the same scumbags
that are that are joined at the hip
right so the one disseminating uh
blatant disinformation like the pizza
gate is a good example from Jack
prostate
um that caused a a psychopath to take a
[__] weapon into a pleat of pizza
place in Washington DC looking for a
basement where a basement didn't exist
yeah that happened but um but well
Batman was a victim Batman exactly right
right measures
he's he's probably has a mental um
instability right A lot of people do but
most people it's a vulnerability that
they focus on that's right most most
people with mental illness or mental
instabilities don't normally want to
kill people that is not a thing it's not
a normal thing they have to be driven in
that direction like you're saying with
possible misinformation
well I would I would argue that
um you know there's there's an acronym
for it called mice and that stands for
money ideology
compromise and ego and those are the way
that people are susceptible right now
it's not just mental illness there's
also people who have been compromised
for financial reasons maybe they're in a
massive amount of debt uh you know I
mean imagine Donald Trump oh sorry I
sneezed spread Kavanaugh I don't know
you know right there there's a lot of
there's a lot of sneezes there's so many
um but yeah it's
these are active measures and we had an
individual named kear Giles uh sorry
guys did it again here Giles here Giles
wrote uh this book Russia's war on
everybody and what it means for you
and and in there and during our
interview he he mentioned you know a lot
of the people who are high level
influencers who are pushing Russian
propaganda and disinformation
uh
are
they're compromised in some way
generally uh they're broken and looking
for revenge on the world uh they've been
compromised in some sort of sexual way
it's very it's dark stuff I'll admit
um but he came on our program on
radicalized Truth survives podcast and
he discussed a lot of this and uh what
It All Leads back to is uh well this guy
and this was a another guest of ours uh
John Sweeney and oops sorry dropped one
uh he is on Twitter
um
and he is absolutely phenomenal he's a
journalist who is in Ukraine right now
uh reporting on
Putin's genocide because that's what it
is
and Putin is not only Ukraine is just
the small kinetic part
of this
World War III we're in currently uh here
in America we are facing attack not just
from external sources you know not just
from these troll farms in Eastern Europe
or Africa or the Philippines literally
they're Global China has them
um but we are also facing and this is
probably the most Insidious attack as
we're facing Putin's fifth column
internally and that fifth column is made
up of people like Michael Flynn Jack
vasovic uh representative rapey
mcforhead who you were showing just
before I came on for anyone who wants to
know who rapey mcvorry is I have full
disclosure uh his name is Matt gatz and
I say it wrong yes a lot of people are
like oh he says it wrong you say it
wrong no I don't [__] say it wrong
it's not [__] spelled I mean it's
g-a-t-e-s God damn it that's how you
[__] say Gates and I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] what he wants
me to call him I'll call him when I want
him to call him and you could just call
him sex trafficker yeah he's a [__] you
know representative sexual ass [__] is
what he is he said well here's the
problem here's the problem uh the thing
that people ignore you know people focus
on the lascivious nature of
he you know paid for sex with an
underage girl
um but what they neglect are the other
details in which he takes underage girls
with him on these
business lobbying trips I guess uh and
he meets very rich very powerful people
and if you have an underage girl to
offer them and then you can blackmail
them with this is all conjecture of
course
um but I would I would argue that's
probably uh what another interesting
individual was doing Elaine Maxwell
um
so yeah it gets into very wait wait wait
who's who's Colleen Maxwell is isn't
that the one that um she's got a hit
song No actually that's the one who
helped him no she's the one that trucks
yeah oh yeah
yeah that's the one that uh when asked
Trump said I wish her well yeah well he
would wish her well because he knows her
uh not only does he know her go ahead no
this gets this gets into conspiracy
areas and I don't really want to go
there but what I would like to talk
about oh why not God damn it I want okay
here's here's a conspiracy for you yeah
what if what if what if authoritarian
governments around the world were
laundering money into the American
electoral system and the reason I bring
that up can you share my screen again
because you guys like to talk about this
guy a lot
yeah George scantos you know the scam
turian candidate yeah that's what we
call him here the Scandal candidate so
so they tried to contact the campaign
donors here right the campaign donors
yes excessive
um amounts of reasons I'm digging I'm
digging through the trash and getting
the T yeah well here's some more pour
you gave here share my share my screen
again for me okay
uh this was January 6th in Gibson go
and if you read down through this
article there's a part I highlighted
down here uh that I think is really
important USA Today emailed everyone who
donated to the fundraiser asking for
comments
only a handful responded
do you see the similarities between the
operations
and if you watch it was episode 88 that
you you we were oh that's right is that
is that the number was that yeah they
[__] get away from me it's we're like
like I I had to show it to someone to
show them the gifts and go thing uh it's
episode 88 if you go to your website go
to playlists and I think it's under full
episodes yeah it is it is or or you can
just search
um 88 that's why I number them on the
titles
yeah that also might find you something
else though well hey what are you gonna
do
why did it have to be 80 .
I don't know I don't know I mean again
it just fell that way that's the day
that you wanted to do it we scheduled I
actually think we pre-recorded that
interview this one's live yeah we did
over the weekend and then we aired it I
think so I think so we used to do that
but now we're like do it live do it live
I don't want to record [__] I want to do
it live yeah and then you got to edit it
you got to add graphics
I have [__] well let's just let's
just do it like so over over at
radicalized truth survives uh what we do
is we do a recording on the weekends and
we do a long form interview we just
spoke with uh Craig Unger who is the
author of American compromat and uh
House Restaurant Putin I've talked about
Hamming him on the show I've talked to
him uh in
DMS about coming on the show I just
never have got to that point yet Craig's
a great guest you would love him uh ask
him about Yuri Schmitz Yuri is a a
defected major from the KGB dude is
awesome you can catch him on Instagram
it's a sh-b-e-t-s
uh he he's got a massive following in
Russia like millions of followers the
only problem is he hasn't gotten to the
putting AI English subtitles on his
Instagram videos so I have to like
translate them and it's real pain oh my
God I wish he'd get subtitles anyway
well so so let me ask you what is what
is Santos because you know I mean we've
had this news about Sam Santos Santos is
uh is an operative he's an agent he's
running an operation he is he is what uh
is known in the intelligence business as
a Chaos Agent and I would argue that
chaos Agents come in many
sizes shapes genders flavors what have
you
uh but the ultimate thing you need to
look for is what happens and George
Santos has been uh quite useful in
drawing everyone's eyes
away from
the fact that the head of
counterintelligence for the Federal
Bureau of Investigation southern
district of New York a man named Charles
McGonagall was recently arrested for
taking money from a fellow named
oligarapaska wait wait we have mentioned
this we have mentioned this on the show
a time or two I believe maybe even
yesterday yeah probably yesterday yeah
and probably the day before that uh
McGonagall
um is going to become a common word here
on the Tony Michaels podcast good and
the reason the reason why uh is
significant because who because
McGonagall I mean he's just another Cog
in in the [__] wheel here uh in in
our politics but the real person that is
significant here is the person who is
paying him money
um and he was laundering money for which
is Oleg deripaska so why why is that
name seems significant
um in the grand scheme of things because
it sounds I don't know that name sounds
Russian to me
oh it's very Russian it's very Russian
uh it's so very Russian he's he's a
Russian oligarch meaning he is a
billionaire
um
there is a murky history around how he
acquired his fortune during the fall of
the Soviet Union uh as we know in Russia
organized crime is basically the
government now
you mean you you're saying the mob the
mob is taking over again well in Russian
it's bratava okay let me show you here's
our audience dear posca is tied to
manafort we talked about this yesterday
you see they're well educated here yeah
they're listening they're listening
they're out there
right see I I don't I I try not to get
too distracted by the [__] like oh
Joe Biden he missed a word today in his
speech I get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense let's pay attention to the
[__] that actually is driving uh um the
separation between democracy and
autocracy in this country let's pay
attention to that because that seems way
more imminent danger than the president
United States missing a word or Miss
saying a word or stuttering a bit in his
speech come on let's do this yeah no
this is uh and and what really amuses me
to no end is how good Joe Biden has been
uh you know the the talking points for
the rights uh prior to the election
we're all China China right uh it's
China China is our enemies can you get
your tiny hands and do a proper
impersonation yeah
that's much better much better sorry I
didn't I didn't mean to interrupt the uh
the flow there I just wanted to give
that in Janet
so tell us why that's significant tell
us
Joe Joe Biden has has he has uh
uh and I don't know if people have paid
attention to this but he has taken China
to the mat uh so much so that China is
complaining uh about our lack of
providing them uh with technology uh
specifically uh computer chips PC chips
chips for devices iot Etc
um it seems like there was an act even
that he passed like to manufacture
microchips here or something which is
funny because you'll hear you'll hear
Trump and his deranged speeches that he
gives around the country you know when
he's trying to grift money and he says
oh I I I held China accountable and I
told them that they owed me money and
it's like no [__] man you had accounts
over in China okay right yeah I believe
he had like 16 million or something yeah
well it doesn't wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait doesn't everyone have 16
million dollars in Chinese bank accounts
I mean come on I have it underneath wow
you're president of the United States
who doesn't have that kind of money in
China while you're the president United
States I mean this is low average
everyday stuff right the problem this is
a counterintelligence problem right the
proper counterintelligence would have
told us that you know uh Trump was
laundering money for the Russian mob
through Taj Mahal and through Trump
Tower and uh you know a guy named David
bogutin I mean
6 million in cash for a bunch of condos
and Trump Towers right I mean I've added
an eyelash I forget the the article but
there was there was an article that that
more or less broke out you know Russia's
involvement within Trump Tower and those
who had leased offices and floors and
all this stuff and I think yeah yeah
there was like 2016 2017 maybe wait I I
almost bet you're gonna tell me that
seder's tied to Russia too but let me
get back to I bet you're gonna say that
all right so let me let's go back to
honestly I'll like Dara posca sorry I
get all these things oligarapaska
what I can't say his name wrong either I
like to say names wrong
okay I'm a word matters kind of guy yeah
yeah yeah well I mean come on man I do
word phrase of the week every week
if you you like words I like to say them
wrong salsa okay go ahead go ahead go
ahead slanchy anyway
uh so oligarapaska is uh one of Putin's
pet oligarchs as a matter of fact uh
olegzarapaska is is so whipped by Putin
that in a a publicly
videotaped Gathering of the oligarchs
and Putin uh in which Putin was
demanding that every oligarch sign this
document basically swearing fealty to
Putin uh he specifically called out
oligarapaska made him get up walk across
the room stand next to him
sign it and then he said don't take my
pen
like he was that rude to him so that
that is who oligar paska is and uh
oligarapaska interestingly enough uh if
you want to talk about tentacles in the
United States
um Mitch McConnell I believe was
instrumental in getting the sanctions
lifted off of oligarapaska so that they
could run an aluminum Factory together
in Kentucky by the name of russol was
oleg's company yeah
so we had sanctions against this Russian
oligarch what could possibly be the
reason that we had the sanctions for uh
uh it was tied to the 2014 Russian
invasion of Crimea
uh and the sanctions that were uh you
know put in place after that it feels
like it feels like we almost forgot
about Putin
um stealing Crimea from well I think a
lot of people have forgotten Putin stole
a lot of things Putin stole chechnya and
installed a a uh incredibly violent
autocratic misogynistic Muslim leader
there uh he stole Georgia
um not to be confused with not to be
confused not the state here Georgia yeah
uh no he just pays people in that state
I mean I mean Donald Trump tried to
literally steal Georgia with 11 800
exactly votes but but Putin tried to
steal the country Georgia not the not
the state here just just so no one's
confused yeah yeah yes the country
Georgia I mean if you look at the you
know I'm a very geopolitical person it's
all networking to me uh Serbia is a node
in this network and the head of
intelligence services for service area
is a
devoutedly pro-russian so that bodes ill
considering you know one of the things
that Midas Touch has done is the podcast
American psya right with Wes Clark Jr
who has also been on our show uh was
Clark Jr uh there was a Serbian
uh in his life when he was going through
all these operations at Standing Rock
and Stuart Rhodes apparently uh had a
Serbian fellow attached to him
yeah I've heard that name Stewart Rhodes
before
it's almost like
um we've had Dakota Von Adams Stuart
Rhodes a strange son and his wife and
Tash Adams on the show and it seems like
my memory serves me that
um Stuart Rhodes is sitting with his his
feet on a concrete floor uh in detention
waiting to be uh sentenced because he
was found guilty of seditious conspiracy
to overthrow our government
I'm just is this the same the same
Stewart Rhodes the oat keeper yeah
uh the one-eyed Wonder Man of the
January 6th Insurrection uh head of The
Oath Keepers
he is uh
yeah
but I would point out something to your
audience that what Dakota Adams uh who
what this young man has stated is that
uh on a show by a fellow named audio
magnet he is declared that uh his father
uh was basically taking orders from
Michael Flynn and a fellow named Eric
Prince
you're bringing up all these names and
it feels like it feels like it's gonna
work you're just gonna say this out loud
this network of people it feels like
that none of them none of them are on
the pro-democracy side of the American
public it really feels like to me that
they all are for one aim and one aim
only
um to kill democracy not support it am I
wrong in saying that I don't I don't
know it feels like you're doing correct
right you are absolutely so explain
everyone knows who Michael Flynn is that
[__] scumbag But Eric Prince is kind
of a um
yeah can you can you tell everyone who
is Eric Prince's sister right uh okay
well so Eric Prince uh he is a
private Army uh CEO I guess you'd call
him he's the head of a private Army it
used to be known as Blackwater yeah they
really ruined the names today to Rebrand
like right Wingers always have to do
yeah yeah and um he is Believe It or Not
A
he converted to Catholicism and became a
knight of Malta uh and this is an
organization that still
1500 years later whatever still thinks
they're fighting the Crusades against
Muslims they're islamist phobic and it's
a long long story I want to point out
something here in the audience we have
such a great audience they know look
Jane says
um Rob knows it's Betsy DeVos is his
sister that's he's the boss this uh uh
on on Twitch they're going on YouTube
Here's Beth they again they our audience
is well informed about the right wing
here so they already know who Aaron
Prince is and I'm sure they know Mike
flindon but tell the significance of why
um what Eric Flynn is to Mike or Eric
Jesus Christ Eric Flynn are they have
they have they [__] combined yet well
somebody somebody told me the other day
that you know he's creating American
Isis and his real name should be Osama
flin Laden so wow
because who said that because I'm
stealing that [__] that they treat uh
that was
someone write it down I gotta memorize
that
he had uh you know Michael Flynn just
the other day was posting about you know
rise up white women basically uh it was
like Suburban white women
are you talking about the home The
Homeschool type [__] that uh because
Jimmy Stewart said we were talking about
some of that yeah well the homeschooling
stuff I mean you can draw a direct
correlation between Michael Flynn
pushing for homeschooling and the couple
here in northwest Ohio which is my state
uh running a uh running a Neo-Nazi
homeschooling curriculum on their
website and YouTube and
yeah it's I mean what they want to do is
they're they've been attempting to
destroy the right wing has been
attempting to destroy education in this
country for at least 50 years I mean the
past the past two weeks have been pretty
clear down in Florida
yeah yeah kids can't read books what are
they so afraid of that they are afraid
of a book
they can't argue against it no no no no
no they're not afraid of a book They're
Not Afraid of a book they're afraid of
the people that they want to mind [__]
and to delude the children they they are
scared that they'll be able to uh I
don't know learn and read and when you
have a population that can learn and
read on their own it's really it's it
becomes more difficult to delude them
um and if you homeschool them if you
actually because listen I'm not saying
every person out there who homeschools
their children because a lot of times
there's the necessity board but if
you're doing it because you're scared
the education system is going to
indoctorate indoctrinate your children
you are actually indoctrinating your
children that is what you're doing
sometimes homeschooling is completely
necessary in situations but if your
reason to homeschool your children is
because you're scared our education
system that we have which is broken by
the way is going is it's design
it's so horrible there's no way our
system is designed to indoctrinate
anyone number one but is designed to
indoctrinate them and that's why your
home is going you are doing that exact
thing I think that's what you're doing
the a good visual of it is a funnel
right you have a wide open uh uh
just area that things can go into
information right but as you go down
let's just say that we break it off into
tears right you if you begin to
homeschool or you are already yourself
as a parent or a person saying I'm
limiting the amount of information and
knowledge that I want to accept right
we're walking into February 1st Black
History Month the first uh class offered
on AP level which is a college prep
course is African-American studies which
we know that Republicans are very
sensitive about because it's going to
bring up some tough things that need to
be discussed right especially during the
60s and 70s with the with the queer
community lgbtq community as well as the
black community but it I would I would
look at it as a funnel
if you begin to go down and you say okay
this person is already limiting the
amount of information or knowledge
they're willing to accept about what
just base reality is right in history
that has happened and then as they teach
that already limited contained amount of
information and knowledge to another
person like their child right it gets
smaller and smaller and smaller where
you really only live on a certain number
of pillars most typically racism white
supremacy it's uh you know something
else that is limited Christian
nationalism National yeah all of these
things that basically like it goes down
into a funnel where the only thing that
drips out is propaganda and pro-fascist
type of ideologies and it doesn't it
doesn't allow for the open-mindedness
collective learning environment that you
would have in a high school especially a
public high school or a public grade
school or something where you have in
Florida and if you you I've seen videos
where it's literally just the children's
library right skinny books that are you
know probably like eight eight by ten
eight by eleven ten by ten pages just
just drawings it's got four words on on
the page and it's like 10 pages all of
those books off the shelves it is a bare
open library in Florida and that is
exactly what they want right well and I
I had someone asked me the other day why
are these libraries empties and it's
because they don't want teachers to have
the resources to teach children how to
read
um because of this [__] scumbag this
is the ideas that and this is what
you're talking about here's here's just
30 seconds of mic Flint so we can get a
taste of it and then I want to know
go ahead I need to point something out
about this picture right here
as you can say as you can see here the
great Reawakening verses and and on the
right you see the reset but it's the the
great reset the great Reawakening versus
the great reset is the title of a book
written by a fellow named Alexander
Dugan who has known colloquially as
Putin's brain he's his Rasputin his uh
cult Whisperer if you will and Michael
Flynn just happened to name his national
tour just coincidence
yeah
well let's let's uh a licensing deal I
don't know let's
maybe they did let's listen to it 30
seconds of this scumbag uh pumping his
Russian Putin propaganda into the minds
of these poor people whatever the
weaponization subcommunity of the new
House of Representatives is going to do
however they prioritize you know we just
had long conversations about that I
don't know what they're going to do can
I influence it yeah you're damn right I
can because I have a national and an
international platform and I try to use
it with great discernment and great
judgment and great influence for the
things that I believe are going to
affect this country
but that's that's how I control that's
how I take control holy [__] not even
hiding it anymore yeah well I would
remind everyone that Michael Flynn is a
psychological operations officer I mean
this is what he did he trained for this
he ran psychological operations in
Afghanistan uh supposedly against one of
our own politicians which I'm not sure
how that's not treasonous but whatever
um
and he is the man who in addition to
being in charge of the Q Anon uh
operation which was started through an
organization named maga3x
um
he also ran surveillance of the
Republican National Convention in 2016.
here in Cleveland Ohio
and what a lot of people don't know
what a lot of people don't know sorry
about that is that
um
yeah
the hotel the Westin where Trump and a
large number of people uh were staying
for the RNC in 2016 was owned by a
corrupt Ukrainian oligarch named Igor or
ior kolamoisky
and that just ties this once again back
to corruption in Eastern Europe and
billionaires and oligarchs
it always leads back to Putin's just a
web of Putin's lies so so tell us why
technology plays such an important role
in all these names of these scumbags who
are trying to
um well really you call that cognitive
War fail right yes so tell us why
technology is so important in the in
their weapons weaponization of cognitive
Warfare well because these chaos agents
such as George Santos uh and even I
would argue chaos agents who you will
find
on the streets
uh or chaos agents that you would find
in the January 6th Insurrection uh
there's a young man named John Sullivan
who they attempted to pin the whole
antifa thing on
um he was a Chaos Agent and as a matter
of fact the black lives matter movement
specifically called him out as such
uh and yet he shows up in the January
6th Insurrection young black man uh
former speed skater
and
not only does he show up but he's
mentioned by name by Rudy Giuliani in
one of Rudy's text messages
hmm well you know it seems it seems all
to be connected I'm just I'm it's money
that's why the technology matters all
these people do fundraising online
Gibson go
you know GoFundMe
um uh you know if money can be hidden
and laundered
through a technology stream
through payment processors
PayPal uh stripe you may know that
PayPal and stripe both have two big
names attached to their founding and
that is Peter Thiel and Elon Musk
you know Elon Musk is currently turning
Twitter into it's almost like he filed
an application
um to become a payment processor on
Twitter I I'm seeming to remember a
story somewhere here this last week that
said Elon Musk was trying to get these
violent application to become a payment
processor right am I crazy in saying
that maybe that has something to do is
that Twitter coin or something like that
is that what it is Twitter coin what
[__]
yeah
oh something yeah I mean I don't know
well here's the thing like you're
listening we get a perfect name for your
um it's gonna be great there's gonna be
a great there's gonna be a great Ico uh
it's gonna be awesome I will say I mean
like even We're Not Gonna Take it into a
spack
oh they could don't audience members
what are you laundering what whatever
you do do not stick your [__] coin in
the spec don't do it it's just something
and it could spread around but we
already and we already know I mean just
a quick side note on the on Elon Musk we
already know what his plans are in terms
of you know he's a he he was on he was
on some interview of I think a year or
two or a few years ago whatever it was
and they asked and they're like oh you
know how would you fix Twitter whatever
and he said basically
paraphrasing here I want to copy and
paste what uh what WeChat has done right
because WeChat if no one knows WeChat is
this basically house for all sorts of
services within China right you could
pay you can do this you can use that
it's all through coming through a single
app yeah right it is just like
whole singular way of life connected
through this one entry point and Elon
Musk being like oh well you know I just
want to do the same thing that's his
whole plan so he wants to and also I
think he was on a call it was an
investor call and some of those notes
got leaked by I forget the reporter's
name but she's been covering most of the
Twitter news on all the layoffs and
everything but she covered that and she
said during this call he was like oh
yeah I want to add Payment Processing so
that you can do this and do that and you
can offer this and I'm like I think he
also stated he wanted to become a
banking Institution
on Twitter
I trust that yeah I know I just I don't
trust
I would not if my if
s are not encrypted and also leaks have
happened just in the last year which
Chad loader had exposed and then was was
suspended from Twitter you know it makes
me think like maybe I shouldn't put my
money into a messaging app that says
they want to be a bank I don't know
that's just my opinion so so here here's
here's uh here's my thing about the
Twitter leak
um given who
Elon musk's primary investment
backer what Saudi Arabia sorry uh I
would argue keep sneezing I would argue
that the the leak of Twitter data uh
that you mentioned uh may have been an
operation in itself for the simple fact
that um
that information being available in the
wild
leads a lot of different institutions to
claim that they have a full set and
verification of the data right
um however
it also gives institutions a reason to
have
all of the data and if Saudi Arabia is
paying for that you have to wonder
you know what activists are going to be
exposed uh what groups are going to be
infiltrated because of this data I mean
we know that activists around the globe
organize on social media
one need only look at Facebook and
Twitter to see that happen
um
it's always back to the technology
it is it is I I'm sorry I'm a computer
geek it's what I do for a living and
it's it's I think it's very very
important people need to start paying
attention to the ways that technology
can be abused I mean just look at the
messaging that's being delivered by
people like Michael Flynn and Jordan
Peterson on platforms such as not just
Twitter
uh but Rumble mm-hmm and and if you go
to Rubble it's absolutely just constant
misogyny and Russian propaganda and
ridiculously that's alpha males baby
that's what they are they're just
outside trying to get by in a beta world
yeah well so one of the things I did uh
last weekend is I I went to Washington
and I went to Washington DC and I
attended a talk bike here
um
about his book you know Russia's war on
everybody
and in this room uh were some very
high-ranking people I I sat next to a a
wing commander in the Royal Air Force I
was very International uh very smart a
very high-ranking uh people
and based on the questions that were
asked in this session
um I'm very very troubled at our
perspectives I I hope that Biden sticks
to his guns I mean right now Putin has
enough cash to continue his his
genocidal war in Ukraine for probably
the next three years
um
we need to stand behind them because if
we don't what we're going to see in
Ukraine uh is exactly what happened to
Poland in World War II
and I don't think Putin will stop he
will continue to roll
through Eastern Europe
um and and then we will have the kinetic
phase of what we're facing right now
which is World War III
well I have a question here from uh
Facebook speaking of technology and
Facebook no I will not fix your computer
sorry Martha Martha ask Martha asked um
and and I appreciate you coming on hi-fi
but she asked what's the name of the
podcast of your guest so Hi-Fi give us
give us your best uh Shameless plug of
the of the show and how you guys are
famous plug yeah yeah do you do
Shameless plugs because you're about to
do one so all right I'm normally a
pretty humble person but uh I talk a lot
of snacks so radicalized
truth survives is the name of a podcast
that I co-host
uh both of my co-hosts have won Emmy
Awards uh Miss Heidi Cuda has won an
Emmy Award for investigative journalism
which we've had Heidi on before yes and
you've also had my other co-host on uh
Jim stewartson yes he won a uh Emmy
Award for I believe game design
um my real name is Josh Fidel
um you can look me up I'm on the web I'm
a technologist just look for the guy
with the beard and the sunglasses you'll
find me
um
And We examined this information
and how Russia is engaging in what is
colloquial known as hybrid Warfare I
think cognitive Warfare is kind of my
specialty
um
information Warfare right uh you know a
third of our country has gone or maybe
10 of our country has gone a bit loopy
and there's a reason for that it's
because they're under attack and they
have been victimized I mean there are
techniques that have been used against
them such as dissociative video which is
any video that is a uh well the the
beating of the young man Tyree Nichols
uh I'm sure that put a lot of people in
an dissociative State and and made them
very unhappy
um and and I would argue that that is
almost intentional
uh because then what happens when people
get into this uh dissociative state is
then you can fill their minds with all
sorts of nonsense such as we are the
only people who can fix this uh look at
these Democrats and their riots you know
whatever Look at police brutality look
at you know it's it's always the the
shiny coin distracting you and splitting
your skull open and you don't even know
it uh the the techniques behind this are
fueled by data scientists and you know
psychologists there are rooms full of
these people uh you know figuring out
how to you know some of them just do
innocent marketing and they try to sell
you products they don't go quite this
far but some of them are trying to fill
people's heads with
absurdities and as Voltaire said if they
can make you believe absurdities they
can make you commit atrocities we've had
Texas Paul say that on here as well
everyone go I like that guy go follow
radicali radicalized pod
um on Twitter you'll be able to put the
uh the links there I put the I put the
YouTube uh channel in the comments so on
any of the platforms you guys are
watching from make sure to check them
out subscribe go go check out the
radicalized truth survives podcast
um Hi-Fi go ahead actually Shameless
plug for your platform yeah uh for you
guys for Midas Touch and absolutely 100
percent for American psya which is just
an absolutely amazing podcast and uh
that bonus episode that just came out
with Dr Steven Hassan
brilliant loved it Stephen Hansen is
great
um at what he does and not not only
knowing the things he knows but being
able to really make it digestible for
someone who doesn't understand those
things so go check out that as well I
appreciate having you on hi-fi again uh
but don't hesitate to come back my
friend
always a pleasure gentlemen thank you
thank you very much everyone stick
around we're gonna go to break and when
we come back and we'll find some videos
of Donald Trump you know being deposed
and acting like a punk ass [__] right
in front of just James don't go anywhere
stick around be right back
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product the pardon blanket I've
got you covered part in blanket
specifically Works to make you feel safe
and cozy after your involvement on
January 6th and if you're one of the
other members of Congress who also
helped with the attempted coup hard and
blanket will protect you too hard and
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
a hundred percent made in the USA don't
delay and get your pardon blanket today
for just 99.99 actual pardon's not
guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
so many names so many right Wingers so
many Trump supporters
involved in Russian disinformation
because it's not surprising
they say one thing and do another
at all times
and the tiny hand little freak is the
king of this he's the king of saying one
thing and doing another holy [__] keep
Sanchez have you seen this video of this
little piece of [__] he he looks like
such a people little boy in this video I
mean the reason why he loves of the
fifth
he was just James is sitting right
across from him when he's doing this
deposition that's the reason why he's
hunched over and he's looking down oh
yeah I mean there's other like he can't
make eye contact with her because you
don't have to be you don't have to be a
body uh body language expert to
understand that when he's like
or when he's hunched over reading or
whatever like he's not in a position of
power right he's he's in he's a beta
always been a beta uh but in this moment
he's really a cuck and you've got Tish
James who you know they're asking the
question she's in the room she's been in
the room for a lot of these interviews
that or depositions that she's done with
his family or his children
which now you're coming to realize that
oh God these people lied of course they
did it seemed like there was a story it
seems like there was a story where Tish
James the Attorney General of New York
has requested from a federal or excuse
me from a state judge to
um sanction
sanction these [__] boneheads because
they lied
um inside their depositions crazy crazy
it's like it all it is almost like
that Donald Trump is broke as a joke and
he's gonna be even broker the more he
lies and the more they lie there's just
a broker they're gonna get it's it's
[__] fantastic but I want to show you
a moment now accountable GOP put this
little clip together a lot of people
have done this but this is one of the
better ones because it takes a small
little snippet of the um the deposition
um and then it takes a video from
something Donald Trump said to his
supporters now remember this is so
[__] important and it's not just that
he's hypocritical in in these
contradictory here the contradiction
matters when he's sitting in a room with
the Attorney General of the state of New
York sitting across from who is Char who
is claiming that he's committed
countless fraud on the state of New York
and civilly suing him to get that money
that he defrauded the state of New York
which he knows will bury his [__]
business for good he knows it and the
reason why he knows it because he tried
to open up a [__] business in New
Jersey to try to transfer all the funds
and she caught him in the act and a
judge now has the Trump organization in
receivership it is all but bankrupt
they're just barring the decision that
will be made in the Civil Trial
but not only that right it wasn't just
that he created another company to
transfer funds over can you remind me
again what the name of that second
company was it couldn't have the word
Trump organization in because that would
be way too obvious I'm sure it wouldn't
have the number two in it would it wait
are you saying that it was called Trump
organization two is that what you're
telling me if I remember correctly no
that's exactly that's exactly what it
was called and that's the reason why she
caught him in the first place doing it
she's like you weren't even like you
weren't even good at hiding right you
know right like at least trying to hide
money his whole life yeah and he [__]
that one up it's ridiculous I mean it's
like it's like when they say like oh the
best best place to hide something is in
plain sight and it's like yeah but not
for this though maybe maybe not maybe
not when you're being sued right and you
just had 17 criminal crap counts that
you were found guilty of on the same
organization they're probably not a good
idea but the context of these two clips
matters because the one the first clip
that you're gonna see from this
deposition is him in a private room with
Tish James knowing that if he says the
wrong [__] thing because
there's a lot of clips and we can and
I'm probably gonna watch one of them
there's one where he explains this is
not fair you're being unfair to me and
anything that I say anything that I say
You're Gonna use against me yeah that's
how it works in the deposition dummy
that's what it's for if you don't want
to be used against you don't say it
right don't say [__] [__] or just
true or or don't commit crimes right
don't give a crimes and then have to
cover up for them but that's a good
point because on the other side of the
screen you're gonna see him be
hypocritical and contradict himself but
it's not the hypocrisy that matters in
the second clip what I want everyone to
understand is he is projecting to his
[__] to his to his dyest hardest of
sheep cult [__] followers that
he doesn't plead the fifth because he
knows he does it's always projection and
the projection is the important part not
the hypocrisy we all know he's a [__]
scumbag we all know he's a [__] liar
and we all know he's a hypocrite we all
know that that's [__] and you don't
have to go very far to prove that [__]
you don't have to you don't need these
two clips to prove that but what this
shows is the is the is what he does to
mind [__] his supporters into believing
[__] that isn't true before it happens
he knows he knows that there was gonna
be a time where he was going to be on
[__] on film in a deposition pleading
the fifth and he's telling his
supporters not watch watch the clip
watch it anyone in my position not
taking the Fifth Amendment would be a
fool an absolute fool if you're innocent
why are you taking the Fifth Amendment
it's always projection Gabe Sanchez
everything I mean he he also taught his
children well you know uh Eric Trump I
believe it's over 500 times he took the
fifth when he was questioned by Tish
James what was the number for trump it
was over 400 wasn't it yeah they're
pretty close pretty close
uh I you know you know you know that's a
that's a funny thing about numbers
my guess is that they don't know them no
no well I'm no that that the the amount
of times that Donald Trump and Eric
Trump pled the fifth because look there
is a scope of the investigation right
there's certain evidence that Tish James
and the Attorney General's office has
that they're using two two [__] bring
suit against Donald Trump and his
organization
um for the frauds that he committed and
they're trying to get their money
basically
for anyone to know is the criminal trial
um brought
1.61 million dollars worth of
restitution criminal restitution that
the Trump organization has to pay which
is the maximum amount that they could
sentence them to under New York state
law now the reason why this James is
bringing the civil case is because 1.61
million is not near enough restitution
of what Donald Trump his business and
his family stole by defrauding the state
in New York she knows that that's why
she's bringing a civil suit right
because she knows the criminal statues
weren't going to provide enough
restitution
so in this case she's gaining
restitution which in all honesty with
the tax returns Trump doesn't have Trump
does not have the money for the
restitution that's why he was moving the
money and that's why the judge ordered
the Trump organization into receivership
because the judge also can see that hey
he probably doesn't have enough money so
I'm not going to let him move money
around because he's going to owe almost
every [__] cent to the state in New
York with the result of this trial
now
the thing about it is is that Donald
Trump and Eric Trump pleading the fifth
almost the exact same amount of times is
because they know certain information
and they're asking the certain questions
pertaining to that information and it's
almost the same questions yeah and
that's why they're pleading the fifth to
almost the same amount of questions
because it's just cut and dry she has
the evidence and she's asking questions
about that evidence yeah and she knows
she knows the answer she knows and I was
probably not all of them obviously well
that's why she that's why she's asking
for sanctions because she knows the
answers to these questions but she yeah
she knows the answers and she knows
exactly what they were doing I mean it
doesn't again doesn't take a genius uh
to know uh what they were doing right
the fact that they were charged
criminally as an organization
um should only give you you know again
if you're the you know a director
managing partner the CEO the president
you know all these various roles that
Trump and his kids have had and you
cannot tell me
that you just go oh I had no idea this
was happening while the company was
running or while I was running the
company I had no idea that was
weisselberg he was making all those
decisions he was he you know he was
putting money here he was buying this he
was doing that he was giving it to this
no that is not you you okay if you
honestly believe that Trump and his kids
who run that company or previously ran
that company
didn't know what was happening in their
own company and the amount of fraud
that's not like a good Flex that's not
that's not the thing you're like oh yeah
well I didn't know anything it's like
that's just I made you a shitty [__]
business person you don't have to use
that he was flexing yesterday he was
flexing yesterday that he was like yeah
I committed those crying to Stormy
Daniels but there's nothing you can do
about it he's like that was a long time
ago well-known people know about it
everyone knows I committed those crimes
right and Stormy Daniels and I'll show
you the Tweet after this next clip but
I'll show you the tweet from Stormy
Daniels like you just [__] admitted
to the crime you [__] oh did you see
the other one about the legs
no but let's let's watch this clip from
the deposition because I I want to show
people an extended part of this
deposition because I want you to see his
body language and how much of a weak
piece of [__] he is uh CBS News is
actually the ones that obtained this
deposition through a Voya or via Voya as
you say Freedom of Information Act uh
suit yeah it was a foia request and they
went back and forth and they finally got
the tape that's why we saw it yesterday
because CBS News finally received the
tape but here's here's a bigger
um uh clip a longer clip of uh the
Cheeto dust you and on her Grandpa
Poopypants [__] his diaper in the
deposition room in her AG speech
she promised to quote shine a bright
light into every dark corner of Trump's
real estate holdings
shortly thereafter she vowed to quote
use every area of the law to investigate
president Trump and his business
transactions and that his
that of his family as well okay so I
want to point something out he's saying
she he means Tish James yeah which is
the Attorney General of the State
University also Law and Order man if
somebody commits a crime you follow Law
and Order well not not if they're
Republicans no right right right now
when he because this little moment and
you noticed he looked up because he
looked up to see if she was watching him
because he's not watching her because
he's such a feeble little man-child that
he can't sit there and talk directly at
her [__] face because he's a weak
piece of [__] oh yeah again the contrast
of him standing on stage in front of his
supporters saying why are you pleading
the fifth you must be guilty if you're
pleading fifth only monsters right only
monsters my only people who commit crime
and here he is in front of the Attorney
General and he can't even [__] look
her in the eyes when he's saying this
[__] he's such a weak [__] he's
such a [__] beta watch
she knows nothing about us this is when
she knew absolutely nothing about us it
was very unfair
oh it's so unfair oh deep Sanchez what
would happen if I committed crime and
then they wouldn't prosecute me and they
were mean to me oh it'd be so unfair for
me to have to go in and tell the truth
get the [__] out of here well also he's
like oh she didn't know anything about
it dude you you do not need someone to
give you an intro dude your reputation
and it's a shitty one precedes you
a lifetime before someone's ever brought
into this world right they know walking
out of the [__] womb oh I know
exactly like a baby fresh out of the
womb you know a little dancing baby
early Millennia baby was like oh I know
exactly who Trump is right but again
anyone born today comes out and they're
like oh yeah I already have that
Knowledge from my parent it's like how
Evolution Works to like oh why do birds
fly south during the winter right or
like why do butterflies migrate here
it's just something that they've
naturally learned through Evolution and
Trump and his family being shitty humans
is just another one of those things
where you come out of the room you're
like oh yeah yeah I already knew that
all right he's a piece of [__] well I
haven't seen this tweet until just now
and it's great and in full disclosure I
actually
um I emailed stormy to see if she come
on the show I haven't gotten a response
yet just full disclosure because I would
have her on I would have storing Daniels
on every week oh that'd be great oh yeah
I would have her on every week uh
Stormbreaker listening hey open
invitation to be on the show
um this is hilarious so mag's may at tea
party girl 69 holy [__] you can't make
this [__] up this is real that that's
the account at tea party girls 69 whoosh
now I don't know I haven't looked up
that account but right I'm curious no
I'm just I'm just saying that's who
Stormy Daniels is responding to yeah
yeah I mean she's been pretty good about
responding to people and having some
friends this is the this is the well now
but then in Max May
um defense she's saying the truth here
right you just cannot shut his fat face
yeah and she's and she's not or she I
don't know who it is exactly but they're
not you know they're they're not a trump
fan let's just keep that out there right
right they're not a trump fan I'm just
I'm just saying right you're saying this
is fantastic in the in the overall
narrative that at tea party girl 69 got
stormy to respond to the comments it
feels like an early username that we
would have on AOL instant messenger and
I know for some people we're dating
ourselves here whoa whoa whoa what but I
feel like most people most people
watching know what aim is well you know
what you know you know what's funny is
that um how long ago because we used to
get the [__] you know when the AOL used
to send CDs the CDs out yeah I used to
collect them all the time at Blockbuster
I made a whole like exhibit whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa AOL and block yeah yeah
dude right when you check out they were
like oh take a free CD so I would always
take free CDs and then I hung them on
Fish Wire and then had them uh use them
as decoration yeah yeah minimize
decoration so they reflected
Jesus Christ just that artistic side of
my brain dude yeah there you go yeah I
used to collect them like [__] candy
dude
you weren't eating them were you okay no
no but people gave him from their van
and I totally took them okay but let's
move on to the uh the comment that Aunt
tea party girl 69 uh made and stormy uh
quote tweeted here she said he opens his
mouth more than I do my legs
God damn got him God damn
um now this isn't the exact tweet that I
was talking about right your mind I
think I know it's the gutter I mean what
can I say it happens
um here here it is here here is the
Tweet because that was that was a
comment in the thread of this tweet
right on the night um stormy of course
we read this
um statement was it yesterday I can't
find remember yesterday yeah yeah
yesterday yeah yeah because that's where
that's Council wrong he's admitted right
right he doesn't know what statute of
limitations actually is because he
doesn't know it hasn't run out on the
actual uh in the state of New York for
the anyways the point is this Stormy
Daniels who who who received the written
check
um
um and and Michael Cohen went to prison
for that chick
um she says thanks for just admitting
that I was telling the truth about
everything I love as she should have
kept my about
and mocking which this is [__]
hilarious that she mocks him here for
his quotations because we've all watched
Donald Trump do junior do the yeah your
bunny ears on Story Time what's his is
his podcast called uh it's called
triggers no no it's called trigger it's
called triggered bunnies triggered
bunnies Okay
um so she makes fun of in moxom here
which is fantastic she says guess I'll
take my horse face quote back out of bed
now mister back to bed now excuse me Mr
former president uh by the way that's
the correct way to use quotations marks
and I make the kids sound because she
gave him the kiss it's a nice sweats
walk
oh my God Stormy this is [__]
fantastic
um of course we all know because we've
tried to figure out why he doesn't
understand how quotation works on this
show because we read his statements
um because he he literally in the the
quotes that he uses is around why is
there you know it's like her name is but
she goes by stormy that's her name so
you wouldn't put it in quotes right uh
uh stormy I don't know what that like
she's not stormy
maybe I don't know I don't know I mean
if you would think you would think it
would be around stormy and nonsense
because that would be one for right yeah
Stormy nonsense going crazy because then
he would be indicating the whole story
right yeah and it's like oh this is all
right it's all [__] right exactly
that would be the pr it needs to move
the quotes down past nonsense yeah
because
but he can't see that far ahead really
but would you use two quotes or would
you use the one and one as like a title
I put the double quotes you put the
double because it's not a title nonsense
well right but if you're trying to
describe something but it's also
interchangeable so it's like you can I I
mostly use this double quotes for stuff
unless it's a full quote and there's
another quote inside or a title then you
got then you got to use the singles
right then you gotta it's like one guy
quoting another guy and then you're
quoting them right it's a quote within a
quote an Inception quote Yeah Yeah and
set to quote Inception Inception quote
maybe that's the problem is he doesn't
fully understand the science of
inception right or just I don't know
grammar in general I'm not that great at
grammar that's why I didn't make fun of
him a misspelling counsel I did right
and I said I said Trump I never slept
with Stormy Daniels also trump it
happened a long time ago oh and it's
Council count the property the proper
Council yeah Council because this is
like city council not like yeah yeah
this is like I have a council of people
like a group of people making a decision
not like a legal counsel right oh my god
well uh one other thing before we go and
I want to remind the audience because I
didn't my mic I know I had my trouble in
the beginning we were trying to talk
about the uh the the FBI beat trade
today I don't know if it's over I don't
know there's big news Joe Biden's gonna
be arrested and go to gitmo I don't know
uh listen listen to me no no intent
no obstruction no intent no obstruction
no intent no obstruction with trump it
there was the Criminal Intent and the
criminal obstruction that's why the
search warrant was issued this search at
the beach house no matter what the media
tries to tell you today or tomorrow the
next day or next week because they're
going to talk about this [__] for a
long time
here's here's here's the skinny on it
here's the skinny on it this beach house
search today is horrible horrible for
Trump and even more horrible for House
Republicans okay Jim Jordan
they keep getting what they want right I
mean even on Sunday uh you had Jim
Jordan be like where's the Raiders
it's like I don't know maybe because he
said hey I got some documents you guys
can just go just go come get them and
you can go look around not only likely I
believe don't touch the sex toys every
single one of Joe bite Joe Batten songs
Joe Budden and every one of his
Corvettes every one of his garages Jim
badden if we're gonna search every
single one of them we need to search
every single property that Donald Trump
owns top to bottom folks top to bottom
that's what we need to be calling for we
need to find we even need to be
searching caskets apparently we need to
be searching everywhere for the
documents that he stole he destroyed and
he and he hid I don't know whatever he
did with him we need to find out we need
to and we need to figure this out we
need to get to the bottom of it
scene is that they didn't find anything
oh wait a second are you tell
you tell small vacation home that Joe
Biden owns that he
after
after after
all this would happen the documents were
moving right you're telling me he didn't
just willy-nilly take classified
documents to his beach home it's almost
like it's almost like him and his
attorneys knew that and they're like you
know what we're gonna [__] with Jim
Jordan yeah we're gonna [__] with him
feel free to [__] with him yeah it's
like my wife Jill she made some
sandwiches and some snacks if you want
some if you get hungry or anything else
let me know bathroom you can totally use
not like Ivanka and Jerry Trump who made
people use the house next door because
they did not allow their secret service
to use them you know it's like don't
worry we're actual people and we care
about you and yeah we obey the law we
[__] will allow you to do your job
it's almost like it's almost like
there's a thing that Republicans love to
say right they love to say why not just
comply comply comply comply okay fine
now we've complied you can say Digger up
I don't know if you know this but we
actually have some merch on uh store not
detoneymichaels.com it's
store.thedonymichaels.com that may or
may not be dig her up merch ooh it's Sam
dig her up if you want some Digger up
merch you might you might want to
consider to go to the Tony michaels.com
click the merch store the Tony
michaels.com click the merch store we're
out of time I wish we could talk more
about this son of a [__] son of a [__]
son of a [__] son of a [__] you're the
best audience in the world I love
spending two hours with you every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch do us a favor
subscribe to the YouTube channel now
we're trying to get to 20 000
subscribers also follow us at Tony
Michael's pod download every single
episode on Apple Spotify Google make
sure to follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels and don't forget to go
over to Twitch download that app and
we're on the up wire Network now
upwire.com just go to upwire.com you can
find all the social media but go to that
YouTube channel it's a great creators
Network there's going to be a lot of
creators joining that network if you
like our content I'm sure you'll like
theirs too
holy [__] is it really Wednesday already
God it is Wednesday well it's not
Wednesday anymore it's over now uh well
I guess we're already on Thursday and
well two more hours Let's Go guess what
tomorrow is tomorrow tomorrow you get to
vote for bonehead of the week so don't
forget to subscribe to the YouTube
channel you go to the community Tab and
you'll vote for bonehead of the week
tomorrow because Friday we'll do bone
end of the week live in the second hour
the Tony Michaels podcast until tomorrow
same time same place Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon